hey guys I'm James I'm Dan and here is
the comment we've decided to highlight
from yes today's video in answer to a
question what is your favorite Jeff
Goldblum movie it's michael clark with
earth girls are easy and if you haven't
seen the film it's Jeff Goldblum Damon
Wayans and Jim Carrey starring as aliens
the crash into Geena Davis is pull see
it's really funny there you go but for
today here's our G s news roundup for
those of you out there in the vast
videogame landscape who haven't played
Mass Effect Andromeda yet or are still
playing it I've got some good news well
we've got some news it's news it sounds
like the games multiplayer it's getting
a harder difficulty mode seems egg packs
missions
Andromeda's multiplayer squad-based
challenges we'll be getting a new
platinum difficulty soon platinum
missions joined the existing bronze
silver and gold levels and will
challenge players to quote take your
skills to the next level this comes just
days after reports that Andromeda will
not be getting any single player DLC and
that a sequel has been shelved the
Andromeda team has also been reallocated
to buy OS recently announced sci-fi
Ironman Gears of War destiny shooter
anthem with a small group staying to
support Andromeda's multiplayer let us
know in the comments if you're still
playing in drama night and if you're
looking forward to getting stuck into
the Platinum difficulty
next up if you aren't a fan of things
that are cringy you may want to steel
yourself because it looks like
Playstations YouTube channel may have
taken microsoft's anthem video from e3
the one where they showed it off on the
Xbox one X and then poorly photoshopped
it to put it on their YouTube channel
yeah NeoGAF uncovered that the clip for
Bioware's new IP actually showed
PlayStation button prompts had been
overlaid over the Xbox prompt not even
particularly well to add insult
impossible injury Xbox marketing manager
Aaron Greenberg yesterday tweeted out
the Forbes news story referencing the
blunder with the caption oops
and the cry laughing emoji now it's not
all that uncommon for the Xbox and
PlayStation YouTube accounts to host the
same footage but the problem here is
that Microsoft's e3 video was showing
anthem playing on the Xbox one X so if
it is indeed the same footage from them
that's a good chance what we saw isn't
representative and what the game would
look like on ps4 or even ps4 Pro also
PlayStation players probably I can see
prompts for left
Bunker's yeah with that now to address
the Bandicoot in the room we've seen a
lot of comments about Crash Bandicoot
even though we haven't covered it but
that means you guys are fans and we've
got good news for you that's right it
sounds like Activision I think about
making more crash games after the
release of the insane trilogy for ps4
acti publishing CEO Eric Hirschberg has
said the publisher is experimenting with
crash right now he explained we know
that a vocal fanbase that wanted that to
come back but you never know if that is
emblematic of a larger audience or just
this niche nostalgia based community so
far we're seeing some real passion for
it so that could lead to other things
Hirschberg added that Activision first
priority is to ensure they are servicing
their community
Sana's Games Got News for today thanks
so much for watching and leaving your
comments we have enjoyed reading them
and we'll be down in the comment section
today so come have a chat happy
Independence Day
[Applause]